in this video we'll talk about
hydrocephalus hydrocephalus is a disease
where excess of cerebrospinal fluid
accumulates in the brain ventricles too
much of cerebrospinal fluid exerts
Associated pressure and that can damage
the brain and
the brain function could be altered
so let's talk about the common signs of
hydrocephalus common signs involve an
unusually large head rapid increase of
head size
when bulging off for tense soft tissue
known as fontanelle which is present on
the top of the head these are some
common signs
now hydrocephalus can be caused due to
reasons first faulty the absorption of
the CSF and secondly overproduction of
the CSF
now these are the brain ventricles and
choroid plexus
so there are lateral ventricles
third ventricle and Fort ventricle
lining all of these ventricle we have a
tissue known as choroid plexus which has
epithelial cells and this tissue is
responsible for the secretion of
cerebrospinal fluid
these tissue secretes the cybrospinal
fluid into the ventricles
now in hydrocephalus the balance between
the cerebrospinal fluid production and
reabsorption is altered
so cerebral spinal fluid is generated by
the choroid plexus as seen by this Arrow
when it passes through the ventricles
and moves out of The ventricle via
cisterna magna and then it circulates
all around the brain
ultimately get reabsorbed
by arachnoid granulation
now CSF reabsorption is really important
if this process is hampered then excess
CSF is accumulated
so overall this is a drainage problem
now this balance is disrupted in
hydrocephalus
so either there is a enhanced CSF
production or there is a less
reabsorption of the CSF all of these can
lead to accumulation of CSF in The
ventricle and that builds up to massive
pressure
which is actually damaging to the brain
now hydrocephalus can be classified into
two forms one is
communicating hydrocephalus another is
non-communicating
in communicating hydrocephalus CSF is
blocked after it is exiting The
ventricle most of the cases it's a
reabsorption defect
now
this is called communicating because the
CSF can still flow between the
ventricles
and of most of the cases the
reabsorption via arachnoid Wheeling is
quality in case of non-communicating
hydrocephalus
the CSF is blocked along the in along
the path of the ventricles
so the CSF cannot move from one
particular ventricle to another
particular ventricle so one ventricle
gets bigger and this leads to our
obstructive form of hydrocephalus
now let us look at these things in bit
more details so here is communicating
hydrocephalus that means there is a
reabsorption defect
generally the overall CSF is reabsorbed
by the arachnoid wheelie or arachnoid
granulation but in this case the
reabsorption is faulty which leads to an
accumulation
now inflammation of the arachnoid
granulation is the key cause of this
kind of communicating hydrocephalus and
inflammation might be due to meningitis
like a bacterial infection or there
could be Hemorrhage in the subarachnoid
space all these things lead to
faulty reabsorption of the CSF
that leads to overall increase in the
pressure in the ventricles
also there could be problems like
choroid plexus tumors that leads to
overproduction of the CSF or
overproduction of one component of the
CSA all these things lead to
communicating format of hydrocephalus
now there is non-communicating form of
hydrocephalus where there could be blood
defect due to which the
the passage wave from one ventricle to
another ventricle is blocked one such
scenario is equilateral stenosis and
this is very common in many individuals
and it's generally congenital and it's
one form of obstructive hydrocephalus
now this leads to a accumulation of CSF
in the lateral ventricles which build up
massive pressure
now there are different molecular
mechanisms which can explain
hydrocephalus or overproduction of the
CSF now several infections such as a
bacterial infection that we see in the
meningitis
that bacterial infection or let's say
Hemorrhage can lead to activation of
specific signaling pathway
so lipopolysaccharides present in
bacteria or let's say the methyl
hemoglobin present in the hemorrhagic
debris all of that can activate specific
tone-like receptor one toe like receptor
is tlr4 tlr4 activation leads to NF
Kappa beta activation which ultimately
via tnf tnf Alpha and Via specific other
kinases such as spec kinases can
actually activate channels that secretes
huge amount of water in The ventricle so
overproduction of CSF occurs so this is
one of the molecular mechanisms out of
many that are described right now these
latest research information are provided
in the description box you can check it
out anytime
now let's talk about the diagnosis of
the hydrocephalus hydrocephalus can be
diagnosed using MRI or CT scan obviously
after birth looking at the overall head
size give us some idea about it but
confirming that and trying to understand
whether the how is how the ventricular
volume has changed or whether there is
any problem in the correct plexus in
order to understand those things MRI or
a CT scan is really important so this is
how the normal brain look like and this
is how a hydrocephalus brain under MRI
look like this image is taken from Maple
Clinic definitely check out their
website link is provided in the
description box
now the most common treatment for
hydrocephalus is surgical insertion of a
drainage system so overall as I
mentioned this is a drainage problem so
one can solve this problem by creating a
side passage and that is known as a
shunt you have one kind of insertion is
taken into The ventricle and that drains
into the abdominal cavity
so and from where it can be reabsorbed
now people who have hydrocephalus
usually need a shunt system for rest of
their lives and this shunt system has to
be monitored periodically
now there are other measures such as
endoscopic third ventricular tummy
and this is basically one kind of
invasive measure surgeons make a hole in
the skull and pass a endoscope through
the brain
which reaches the ventricle from where
it can scoop out a little bit portion of
the identical and ultimately connecting
all the ventricle making up way for the
adrenic system
now in summary we have learned
there are two major type of
hydrocephalus communicating non and
non-communicating now there are
communicating hydrocephalus which can be
caused due to congenital problems
developmental angility factors
now non-communicating hydrocephalus can
be
Emirates infection neoplasm
Etc
now there could be other treatment
options in case of communicating
hydrocephalus generally using a shunt is
good enough but in case of
non-communicating uh hydrocephalus there
could be other particular treatment
options like evc's and burning out the
choroid plexus to reduce the CSF
production Etc
many more nodes regarding these topics
can be obtained from my Facebook page or
my Instagram page don't forget to follow
that you can find a lot of dynamic
flashcards which would help your
revision
don't forget to like share and subscribe
my course is present in an academy which
is India's biggest online learning
platform using our code ap10 can you can
get 10 discount
see you in